плагіатор
Академічна негідність року вбивця
історії руйнівник системи освіти і це як
мінімум кілька і епітетів які ми
окреслюють так званого міністра шкарлета
він повернув освітню сферу часи ручного
управління
відкочував реформи зокрема замашки на
ЗНО відміна ДПА активний наступ на
історію України в найгірших табачників
традиціях зупинені реформи харчування
нуш і реформи в науці під приціл
шкарлета попадали незалежні органи та
інституції зокрема серед яких
національний фонд досліджень шкарлетне
визнавав вибори коректора могилянки
тільки із власної помсти в незаконний
спосіб що займався фальсифікацією
виборів ректора державного
біотехнологічного університету подання
недостовірної декларації і це лише те що
було на поверхні навіть заяву ми маємо
не від шкарлута а від шарлета бо не мав
напевне звідки списати як має правильно
виглядати заява добре що його зараз
звільняють але в мене питання його зараз
звільнять і потім відправить послом в
якусь країну псувати відносини з тою
країною як це у нас відбувається з
відставниками хто буде відповідати за
втрачені можливості хто буде відповідати
за розвал системи освіти хто буде
відповідати за те що зараз українська
школа по суті продукує велику частку
неуків бо система була зламана і мені
видається що ця відповідальність має
бути не тільки у шкарлута а і у тих хто
за нього голосував за його призначення у
тих хто його стільки років покривав і те
чи їй команді він прийшов на свою посаду
шкарлетові ганьба але відповідальність
мають понести ті хто весь цей час його
покривав